the number one place to get memberships
during the joe biden era is of course
join pakman.com grab a membership
get instant access to the bonus show the
commercial free audio feed the
commercial free video feed
all of that great stuff plus the feeling
of knowing you are
supporting an alternative to homogenous
corporate media
joinpakman.com is the place to do it and
what a day to do it by the way there
are increasing discussions as we
transition
from donald trump to joe biden about the
possibility
of joe biden pardoning donald trump
and we have heard from folks on the
right
we've heard even from some folks on the
left
we've heard from national security
figures and others
maybe joe biden should do for the
country
what gerald ford did for the country
to richard nixon which is to pardon
nixon
the way that joe biden could pardon
donald trump
i think that this is a disastrous idea
and under no circumstances whatsoever
should joe biden pardon donald trump
first of all merely on the facts trump
has been way worse than nixon
much more weaponized much more dangerous
to the united states
uh in in terms of what the us
is supposed to be as the democracy
and everything else that we believed up
at least
until donald trump was elected the u.s
was supposed to be
secondly the mere idea that you would be
able to unite
with these absolutely delusional
trumpists if joe biden were to pardon
donald trump
is a complete and total fantasy and so
when i hear anecdotally people across
the political spectrum
to differing degrees saying i don't know
maybe joe biden should look at pardoning
donald trump
absolutely not uh let's look at some of
the arguments
one argument is if biden pardons
trump it prevents trump from pardoning
himself
which would be terrible but the timing
doesn't make any sense by the time
biden can do the pardoning trump can no
longer do it maybe the idea was
if biden sends a signal that he'll
pardon trump then maybe trump would
doesn't make any sense it
makes absolutely no sense whatsoever it
wouldn't get a single trumpus to
cooperate with the biden administration
it just will never happen
and if you've been paying attention the
last four years how could you possibly
think
that there's anything joe biden could do
that would get
a significant portion of trump is to
cooperate with the biden administration
i heard
former fbi director james comey for
example suggesting a pardon quote
as part of healing the country
and getting us to a place where we can
focus on things that are going to matter
over the next four years give me a break
jim
the trump wing of the republican party
is not going to heal
they're not going to participate in any
healing at least that's for sure
if joe biden were to pardon donald trump
it wouldn't make any difference it will
become
it actually may be worse it may become
part of the conspiracy theories they
will say well biden was
forced to do it as part of a deal to
protect
hunter or some kind of hair brain thing
it won't work
it's it's nuts to think that it would
another reason not to pardon donald
trump
is that we need trump and his family to
be as
busy as possible dealing with civil
lawsuits
investigations and possible charges that
will come
to the trump organization to the trump
campaign and maybe even to trump and his
family members as well
because that may actually be what
prevents donald trump from running again
in 2024
let's not give trump any escape from
years of being stuck in a legal hellhole
which is likely where he's going to end
up now
in contrast to richard nixon
richard nixon had not been impeached
richard nixon resigned
to avoid impeachment after he lost the
support of the republican party
republicans went to richard nixon and
said it's over
we will have to convict you in an
impeachment if you don't resign
and nixon resigned contrast that which
with what happened with trump trump has
been impeached twice
and republicans have basically stayed
with trump
okay mitt romney on one count in the
first impeachment voted to convict
so far we don't know when the second
impeachment trial of trump will be
but so far 10 republican members of the
house
voted to impeach trump last week but the
vast majority of republican voters are
still with donald trump
with nixon there was actually a reason
to say listen
republicans came together with democrats
they all went to nixon
and they said you've got to go we will
impeach if you don't go
there is at least more of an arguable
defense of pardoning nixon
the trump fiasco is the opposite trump
has refused to even consider
that he did anything wrong never mind
resignation republicans
stood by trump during impeachment number
one despite obvious signs that trump
must go
and he was descending further and
further into the authoritarianism that
we saw around the november 2020 election
so by pardoning trump you are in effect
also excusing the behavior of the
republican party
in standing by him and in spreading
disinformation
so the situation is drastically
different and then lastly
although trump and the republican party
claimed to be the party of law order
they're not we saw trump's scofflaw
nature
his entire presidency we saw the january
6th trump riots
we know that they are the furthest thing
from the party of law and order for joe
biden to pardon trump
would be to effectively say you are now
immune
from law breaking joe biden should be
the president of law and order
which means he can't pardon donald trump
but on the other hand
it should be joe biden will not be
involved in any trump investigation joe
biden should simply say
to his justice department to whoever i
will have nothing to do with
investigations into the former president
i won't ask you to investigate and i
will not ask you
not to work through the evidence work
through allegations
and do what you need to do that's law
and order
what trump has done is not law and order
now is there any reason to think joe
biden plans to pardon donald trump there
is not
joe biden has previously said he would
not pardon trump
we know lately more and more people have
been saying
biden should pardon trump but hopefully
as far as we know right now
joe biden has not changed his mind on
that and i hope that he does not if you
disagree with me let me know
i want to hear from you